hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast statistical methods for bulk
and single cell rna seek experiments we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinths i am judy o'rourke and i'll
be your moderator for today's event we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green q a button
lower left i would now like to introduce
today's speaker christina kandorsky phd
dr kendorsky is a professor of
biostatistics and medical informatics at
the university of wisconsin-madison
i will now turn it over to dr kanjorski
for her presentation
thank you judy and thanks for the
organizers for inviting me to speak i'm
happy to have the opportunity to talk
today about statistical methods that my
group has worked on for both bulk and
single cell rna-seq experiments so this
is joint work with a number of my
students both past and present and the
three that were involved the most are
listed here
so this work was motivated by a
collaboration that i have with jamie
thompson's lab and as many of you know
in 1998 the thompson lab developed a
technique to isolate and grow human
embryonic stem cells in cell culture
thereby establishing the first human
embryonic stem cell line
over the years these stem cells have
proven remarkably useful for
studies of basic biology especially
those concerning development and they're
also a remarkably useful source of cells
for regenerative medicine
now in spite of their utility there's
much political controversy surrounding
human embryonic stem cells and there's
also questions associated with
compatibility and so in part to get
around these challenges in 2007
the thompson lab published an approach
to convert human skin cells back into
cells that are almost identical to the
human embryonic stem cells thereby
establishing induced pluripotent stem
cell lines
now if the ipsc lines were not almost
identical but indeed identical to human
embryonic stem cells then they'd be
desirable for research for at least most
studies because their derivation is less
controversial and also because they
introduce the potential to
um to sort of create or develop
patient-specific embryonic stem cell
lines um thereby attenuating potentially
some of the problems associated with
immuno incompatibility but they're not
identical and so a focus in the thompson
lab as well as other labs that use these
lines is characterizing the differences
at all sorts of levels so that we better
understand their implications on
downstream studies and so the thompson
lab and other labs look at all sorts of
genomic measurements in an effort to
characterize those differences and i've
listed some of those measurements here
they look at mutations
methylation patterns protein our group
got involved when
the questions were associated with
identifying differentially expressed
genes and also importantly for today's
talk identifying differentially
expressed isoforms between human
embryonic stem cells and induced
pluripotent stem cell lines so an
experiment that i'll talk about in some
detail uh is given in brief the outline
is given in brief here we have four
human embryonic stem cell lines versus
four induced pluripotent stem cell lines
um
messenger rna was sequenced using the
genome analyzer ii
reeds were mapped back to the genome
using bowtie and expression was
estimated using rsem and this experiment
is repeated in triplicate
so the question again that we got
involved in was can we identify
differentially expressed genes but also
can we identify differentially expressed
isoforms in this particular to group
rna-seq experiment
so for those of you who might not be
familiar i'll briefly review the
background behind an rna-seq experiment
so in an rna-seq experiment messenger
rna is isolated in some tissue of
interest
it's reverse transcribed into cdna
fragmented the cdna fragments are then
sequenced sequenced reads are shown here
as colorful lines they're mapped back to
the genome or some reference
transcriptome and it's the data here
that's shown on the right schematic of
that data that we use to get estimates
of expression once we have estimates of
expression we go on to do things like
identify differentially expressed genes
or identify differentially expressed
isoforms now
excuse me when we
started addressing this problem there
were already a number of tools in place
for accomplishing many of these tasks
and this slide is dated and it's sort of
the landscape at the time that we were
looking at a few years ago a number of
tools in place for aligning reads back
to the genome for estimating expression
and importantly for identifying
differential expression most of them
like d e c h are basic or at the gene
level um
coptic was available for identifying uh
differential expression of both the gene
and transcript or isoform level
so we weren't in the business of making
more work for ourselves we thought that
we would apply these methods to our
problem of identifying differentially
expressed isoforms and if they worked
well for that task we would have used
them but most of these methods are not
appropriate for identifying differential
expression at the isoform level and so
i'll spend some time today telling you
why
so
just about all of these methods i think
all of the ones that i've listed for
sure um make common assumptions about
the way in which counts are distributed
so they assume
that uh read counts or estimates of
expression are distributed as negative
binomial with some shape and scale and
here i denoted that shape and scale as
being a mean and variance simply because
the shape and scale determine the mean
and variance so you can think about it
as counts being distributed as negative
binomial with some mean and variance and
the way in which these methods differ
primarily is the way in which they
estimate the variance so how is the
variance estimated most of them rely
on some approach
that looks at this relationship between
sample specific estimates of the
variance have a specific estimates of
the mean and they fit some curve that
describes this relationship
so they might use this in different ways
but most of them to estimate variance
rely on
assessing or quantifying the
relationship between the mean and the
variance
okay the the thing about using this is
is there's only one curve that's used
with each method when they're looking at
the gene level and this relationship
changes with isoform complexity so the
isoform case this curve is is a little
bit more complicated
so what do i mean by isoform so that i
can define isophone complexity so here
i'm showing you
um
three different isoforms coming from two
different genes so here i have gene g
and gene g prime and an isoform is just
an mrna transcript that comes from a
gene
in in the first case gene g it's the
simplest case we have one isoform that's
unique to that gene
in the second case gene g prime we have
two isoforms so isoform g1 is unique to
its parent gene
and isoform gene prime one and isoform g
prime two are not unique to their parent
gene there's two isoforms coming from
that gene so ng denotes the number of
isoforms coming from the parent gene mg
equals one in the first case we have one
isoform mg prime equals two in the
second case we have two isotherms and
what i'm talking about when i say
complexity has to do with how big ng is
for a given gene
so if we go back
to the slide that i showed you before
the schematic of an rna-seq experiment
the data that we use to estimate
expression
excuse me
um is shown just above i don't think you
can see my pointer it's shown just above
this box to get expression estimates
right so
this is the type of data we would use to
get estimates of expression now how do
you use those reads that are mapping
exons to get estimates of expression
well in the ng equals one case it's kind
of easy
okay you it's kind of easy you just use
the
the reads that map
to the constituent exons but in the ng
prime equals two case it gets a little
bit more complicated because what do you
do
to the reads that are mapping to exon
two those blue reads there
you want to divvy them up in a way to
the isoforms that's directly
proportional to their expression but
that indeed is the quantity that you're
trying to estimate so that is a little
bit more complicated and because that's
more complicated there's increased
uncertainty in isoform expression
estimates for more complex isoforms
so let me
repeat that expression estimates for
complex isoforms those for which mg is
greater than one have increased
variability in their expression
estimates because of this problem that i
just mentioned
and that increased uncertainty needs to
be accommodated if if uh you want
improved inference so going back to the
picture that i showed you earlier
um here we see variance as a function of
the mean and this is for all isoforms
shown in red
here's the curve if we just look at the
simple isoforms the ones that are unique
to their parent gene
here's more complexions isoforms ng
equals one and here's even
i'm sorry m equals two and then shown in
green even more complex isoforms and g
equals three or greater so what you can
see is that there's reduced variability
in the simple case compared to all the
isoforms and increased variability in
the others
so if you're using let's say the red
curve when you should be using the
yellow curve you're using an increased
estimate of variability and so when you
think about a test statistic where we're
looking usually a test statistic for
this type of two-group analysis looks
like a difference in sample means in the
numerator or some function of that and
then an estimate of variance in the
denominator if you're using an estimate
of the variance that's too big then
you're underpowered to identify
differential expression
whereas in the other cases if you're
using an estimate of variance that came
off that red curve when you should be
using one that's in fact larger you're
using an estimate of the variance that's
too small
use an estimate of the variance that's
too small you have increased false
discoveries
okay
so we look to see that i just showed you
that for one data set and uh i'm showing
this again like how big of a problem is
is this really going to be in terms of
downstream analysis we looked at that
before we decided that we needed to
develop a new method so here i'm showing
you our sun process data or some process
data from the thomson lab rsem is one
method that's used to get expression
estimates
and here for for this region that i have
marked on the left hand side i'm showing
you for all isoforms that have an
estimated mean that falls within that
region i'm showing you box plots of the
variance for all of the isoforms and
then for the simple isoforms mg equals
one and then the more complex isotherms
ng equals two and mg equals three and
you can see
that in terms of the median variance
there's quite a bit of difference we're
talking orders of
gold change um twofold change in some
cases or more
so let's look at data from another lab
we see the same kind of pattern
we can look at data processed in a
different way so this is not an rsam
effect here's rc process data so rseq is
another method for processing expression
data and we see the same type of pattern
um this is maqc data so microarray
quality consortium data this is a
publicly available data set and that one
that we
have here from one of my collaborators
cufflinks process data so cufflinks
is a method for
estimating expression again and this is
another labs data and we see the same
kind of pattern
so
looking at these types of things and
then
doing simulations where we assessed okay
when the variance does differ
in a way that matches what we see in
real data what is the impact in terms of
power and fdr
estimated by simulation studies so we
did a bunch of simulation studies and
convinced ourselves that in fact this is
an issue that needs addressing and so we
developed yet another approach for
identifying differential expression for
rna-seq data but this one was focused on
identifying differentially expressed
isoforms it can be used at the gene
level but it was developed for uh
isoform level data
and um it was published in
bioinformatics a couple of years ago so
let me give you a bit of background on
that approach
okay so it's called ebc it's an
empirical base approach
and like all of the other approaches it
too assumes that counts are distributed
i'll just underline that here try to
underline it with this funny triangle
counts are distributed as negative
binomial again with some shape and scale
and that shape and scale determines the
mean and variance
then we assume that we have a prior
that accommodates variability in the
true underlying latent level of
expression across the experiment so
here's the way the thought process work
we assume that some genes have some
latent level of expression latent level
of expression means we don't know the
level of expression it's the target of
our experiment it's what we wish we knew
it's what we would know if there was no
biological and technical variability
it's a true underlying level of
expression for that gene some genes have
low
mean some genes have truly high mean and
that latent level of expression varies
across the experiment across all the
genes so we use a distribution to govern
that variance within the experiment and
that distribution is a beta distribution
shown right here
now conditional on having a given mean
we assume that counts arise as negative
binomial parameterized by that mean so
we can see in this yellow distribution
here there's some variability around
some latent level of expression that
variability is due to biological and
technical variability
so these are the two components of the
model we have an observational component
that describes fluctuations due to
biological and technical variability and
we have a prior component that describes
fluctuations due to differences and
latent level of latent levels of
expression across the experiment
now that's the setup for a given
condition but of course we're interested
in two conditions
so the top part of the slide is what i
just showed you again x the expression
of isoform given isoform
or gene um
in a given sample s
is distributed as negative binomial and
here i'm showing
you the specific parameterization that
we use but i'm interested of course on
whether or not these late levels of
expression match across conditions if
they do
i say there's equivalent expression and
the qs are the same q is determined for
fixed r the
mean level of expression and if there's
differential expression the cues are
different
so because i don't know which case i'm
in i introduce a two-group mixture model
and i say the data arise out of the
following mixture model there's some
probability p naught that there's
equivalent expression there's some
probability p1 that there's differential
expression
f naught is the marginal predictive
distribution under the null of the
equivalent expression and f1 is the
marginal predictive distribution
under the alternative of differential
expression
so a couple of things to note about this
model
the first is that the prior that we put
down depends on isoform complexity group
so this is the main way in which
this approach differs from another from
most of the gene based approaches it
specifically accommodates isoform
complexity or the differential
uncertainty that we see
in just different isoform groups
and it's through that prior now if
you're applying this approach at the
gene level then ng equals one for
everything and that's why this is
readily uh applied at the gene level
okay another thing to note is that the
form of this marginal predictive
distribution under the null is a beta
negative binomial that'll be important
to
note later on or maybe just something
you want to know for later on
those are sort of two points about the
specific model parameterization that we
use but i want to make a few points
about mixture modeling in general the
first that we see in this blue block
blue box is that i have a two component
mixture model
because there are two options for the
ways in which these latent means can
sort themselves out across condition
but if i had three conditions let's say
then there are five ways in which the
means can sort themselves out they're
either all the same
or they're all different for the first
one different differs than the other two
or the middle one difference than the
other two or the last one differs from
the other two and so there's actually
five ways
in which latent levels of expression
sort themselves out across conditions
when you have three conditions and if we
do have that case then we can easily
introduce a five component mixture model
and we can evaluate in the context of
this framework the posterior probability
that the gene or isoform falls into any
of those groups so this approach when
when
lots of approaches say they naturally
extend to multiple conditions but if
it's an approach that's maybe t-test
based or something like a t-test when
you get into multiple groups you move
into something like anova and although
you can identify in that case genes that
have some change it's more difficult to
figure out where the change actually is
whereas in the mixture model based
approach you have a specific number a
posterior probability that tells you
uh
quantifies the
places that may be different for the
specific isoform of a specific gene the
first
condition looks different than the other
two conditions and those other two
conditions look similar we can actually
quantify
those
those
possibilities second thing to note about
this modeling framework is because we
make an assumption of conditional
independence the marginal predictive
distribution under the alternative is a
product of the marginal predictive
distributions under the null so if you
don't
like the beta-negative binomial or you
have a different type of data and the
beta-negative binomial doesn't hold but
another parametric family will hold if
you can code up the marginal predictive
distribution under the null you can
simply provide it as a family in the r
code of ebc and all of this other
machinery will work for you em can be
used to estimate parameters you can
check diagnostics and you can evaluate
posterior probabilities of different
patterns so in that way it's fairly
flexible
finally um
i i sort of stressed this when i talked
about evaluating posterior probabilities
of other patterns but
in this context we can
evaluate and quantify the posterior
probability of equivalent expression
just as easily as we quantify the
posterior probability of differential
expression so in some studies especially
the one we're interested in we don't
just want to know with high probability
which genes or isoforms are different
but we would also like to quantify genes
and isoforms that we know are the same
and in the mixture model framework both
interpretations are equally valid unlike
a frequentist framework
okay
so
to evaluate this
we conducted a simulation study where
counts were distributed as negative
binomials so again this doesn't we're
going to compare to other methods and
this assumption doesn't violate any
other methods because everybody assumes
that counts are distributed as negative
binomial we have 90
of the isoforms are equivalently
expressed 10 are differentially
expressed
um
we take the form of the variance from
edge r so there might be a slight
advantage toward the edge arm of it
because we assume the variance follows
the form that they assume in their paper
and parameters and sample sizes were
taken
to match case study data
so the data looks somewhat realistic we
hope
excuse me
that's one set of simulations the second
set of simulations is
we simulate eighty percent of the ice
forms to be equivalently expressed
um ten percent to be differentially
expressed as in the first
is in the first set
but the remaining ten percent we
simulate to have outliers and the
outliers again are are sampled from
um
we take one sample we multiply by four
six eight or ten again to match what we
see in data
so we simulate two hundred data sets one
hundred with and one hundred and fives
this plot is just put in here to show
you for um
with the simulated data we check that
many of the features that we see
in real data are preserved in the
simulation so here we're looking at the
over dispersion parameter which
determines the variance in
hr excuse me
and we want to see that our simulated
over dispersion parameters
or let me say over dispersion parameters
calculated from simulated data
are not too different after we add the
differential expression component than
they are from what we observe in real
data and we can see that that's the case
so the simulation is shown these are
just cumulative distribution functions
the simulation is shown in my clue
pink is
uh the microarray quality consortium
data it looks a little bit like an
outlier because much of that is
technical reps not biological reps and
so our simulation looks reasonable with
respect to this diagnostic
here we have some results so at the top
we're looking at power and fdr for the
isoform level simulation with coptic
um compared with ebc
so with custom
they have a sort of a filter where
they don't test some genes for various
reasons they may do a preprocessing and
determine that this gene isn't the data
that gene is maybe too variable or it
has a potential outlier and so that gene
isn't um considered okay you can
override that filter and you can run
coptif on all the genes and when you do
you get the results that we show here
power's thirty three percent fdr is
point two percent if you reduce the data
set by only considering the genes that
cuptif considers to be okay you increase
power for a reduced set of genes and fdr
is well controlled so
coptic uh seems to have very well
controlled fdr but the power is quite
low compared to other methods ebc
in contrast has a reasonable fdr our
target fdr here was five percent we're
at about 5.2 percent on average across
the simulations
with uh about 72 percent power
on the right is the same type of
comparison but at the gene level so we
see a number of methods for identifying
differentially expressed genes again ebc
can be used for gene level data although
it was designed for isoforms we have
reasonable power at a pretty well
controlled fdr
and then here's that was for simulation
results but we also evaluated the
approach using publicly available data
where there's a gold standard list of
genes and the gold standard is defined
by rtpcr so this is a list of genes that
people think are in fact truly
differentially expressed and we can see
that evc works fairly well um and most
of these methods work fairly well on
this somewhat artificial dataset
okay so in terms of case studies i've
told you about the first case study in
the thompson lab
i won't go into detail about the results
in the gold lab except to say that in
our paper we show that the results that
we see quantitatively in the thomson lab
are reproduced for the gold lab data so
this is not
um the conclusions we draw are not
specific to a particular lab or a
particular type of data
processing pipeline and we definitely
hope they're not specific to just the
simulations that we've conducted we
think we've shown that they're not
okay so in the human embryonic stem cell
an induced pluripotent stem cell
experiment
we applied our approach along with two
others d e seek and edge r to that two
group experiment and here's a venn
diagram showing the numbers of genes
that were identified in each of those
we're going to take some time comparing
the 90 that ebc identifies to
identifications from edgar so here's a
heat bond of the 144 genes identified by
edgar that are not identified by abc
but they are identified by dec as well
and you can see them here
let me see if i can
point with this thing
um
many of these look okay
but many of them look like they might be
outliers in this region here
right
this is in contrast to those that are
identified by ebc
where many of these look okay but the
ones i'm showing highlighting in this
red line looks like they
might be outliers
now
calling a gene differentially expressed
because it has an outlier if it's
equivalently expressed that has an
outlier would be a serious false
positive that we don't want to make at
the same time for the data that's in
this lower end right here
it looks like there may be differential
expression in the presence of an outlier
right the genes truly differentially
expressed and one set of samples is an
outlier that column would be valid so we
kind of wanted to see if we could
delineate between those two
possibilities
and
i i um show this part to
sort of illustrate how we
try to figure out the differences
between a false call of differential
expression
because of an outlier versus a true call
of differential expression in the
presence of an outlier and i also show
it because i think it illustrates the
power of the mixture model approach when
you move up to multiple conditions so i
want to go back to our two group
experiment where we have a two component
mixture model and again the number of
groups determines the number of
components in that extra model when you
have two groups you have two
possibilities there's equivalent
expression the means are the same
there's differential expression the
means are different so here i'm showing
you that two group model in picture
pictures
i have conditions
on the left hand side right here two
conditions four replicates within each
condition and i have equivalent
expression
and differential expression and so with
differential expression we can see
because the color differs between
condition one and condition two uh
that's that's what i'm
that's what i mean by a pictorial
representation of differential
expression as the color differs between
those two conditions
so here's what the 18
component mixture model looks like
and why do i have 18 components
well i mentioned that that experiment
was repeated in triplicate so what we're
looking at here are 12 replicates from
induced pluripotent stem cell lines
12 replicates from human embryonic stem
cell lines
and you can see here's the the pattern
of equivalent expression the latent
levels of expression are the same across
both conditions here's differential
expression the induced pluripotent stem
cell line their latent mean differs from
the human embryonic stem cell lines
the following eight patterns represent
equivalent expression all of the
conditions have the same
expression shown in yellow with the
exception of one replicate that's done
in triplicate one cell line that's done
in triplicate and that has differential
expression so these i would consider
equivalently expressed with one outlier
one
cell line outlier
and over here we see there's
differential expression
the ips lines are different than human
embryonic stem cell lines but there's
also an outlier present so these would
be valid calls and over here valid cause
of differential expression in the
presence of an outlier
over here not valid calls these are um
eight patterns that are equivalently
expressed but they contain an outlier so
we can fit this mixture model to the
data and we can evaluate posterior
probabilities of being in any of those
patterns to try to figure out if these
are false calls due to an outlier or if
these calls are okay when we do that
we see
that uh the one the the
genes that i've marked here with a star
have a very high posterior probability
of being equivalently expressed with an
outlier
now i should stress that
this model is a bit unfair to edger
because it's an ebc model so we fit our
own model to the data and so we might be
expected to do a little bit better so
then we can just look at the data so
let's just look to see
here are nine genes that are called
differentially expressed by edge are but
they're called equivalently expressed by
ebc
and the evc
18 component mixture model identifies
them as having a very high posterior
probability of being in the equivalently
expressed with an outlier category and
so you can see for genes like this i
think we would have to agree that this
thing looks
not differentially expressed it looks
like it's equivalently expressed but it
was probably called because it had an
outlier
and
although
ebc didn't have any that came up with
high posterior probability of being
equivalently expressed with an outlier
we can look at the highest ones just to
see what they look like and here they
are
so these don't have super high
probability of falling in that pattern
but these are the nine highest just to
be fair and these do look a little bit
better i think in terms of being truly
different actually expressed
okay
and then the final thing i said about
the mixture model approach is that we
can not only quantify differential
expression that we can just as
validly
validly or just as validly quantify
equivalent expression
and um that's been of interest to us for
a number of reasons one is we're
interested in identifying differentially
expressed isoforms that are in
equivalently expressed genes so here's
um a number of pairs where we find i'm
showing you these are genes with three
isoforms and we can see in the two
conditions
for we'll take one here that's very
obvious this one right here
we can see that gene expression looks
very similar this is expression on
the y-axis the gene expression levels
look very similar but the isoform
expression levels are different
okay so in summary
uh methods for identifying differential
expression at the gene level in an
rna-seq experiment don't work well for
isoforms because they don't accommodate
differential uncertainty in isoform
expression estimation
ebc identifies both degenes and isoforms
it accommodates uncertainty and it is
robust to outliers i don't talk too much
about that
and it can be used with more than two
conditions and to quantify equivalent
expression
okay so we've extended this approach
to ordered rna-seq experiments and this
too was motivated by a study in the
thompson lab so the thompson lab
is interested in this axolotl creature
largely because it has amazing
regenerative potential when you sever
one of its limbs it grows back
almost completely it grows back
completely almost throughout the
lifetime of the axolotl
whereas in mouse we see almost no
regenerative potential
even though a number of genes involved
in regeneration and axolotl are present
in mouse so we're interested in
comparing
gene expression patterns in mouse and
axolotl
at seven positions along the limbs so
sort of proximal to distal
along the limb and we can do this first
in mouse that's the data that i'll show
you and then ask are they the same as an
axolotl
so this work was published a couple of
months ago
in bioinformatics and it's called ebc
hmm because we introduced a hidden
markov model to accommodate dependence
over time
okay so here's what the data looked like
generally speaking
we have genes
over here you think about a data matrix
and we have multiple conditions
condition one condition two condition
three and these are ordered in some way
so it could be over time or in our case
it's over position along a limb
and we find it useful in this context to
introduce three types of paths the
constant path
where
expression is not changing across
conditions the dynamic path where
expression is constantly changing so at
every transition we see some change
and then the sporadic path where there
are some transitions of no change and
some transitions of change
those three examples are shown here
so to accommodate
dependents in
across the transitions we introduce a
hidden markov model and it's quite
simple we have states and the state
space consists of three states
it specifies each state specifies some
potential change
and we consider the up down and no
change conditions so i'm talking about
state uh
states that describe transitions so
changes in expression across adjacent
points
and what we're interested in is how
these states sort themselves out across
the transitions so do we see
equivalent expression
excuse me intermarcus equivalent no
change
and then maybe up
up up all the way or or something
different what are those state what's
that state profile across the transition
space
in the dynamic case
for both of these we introduce an
auto-regressive component to describe
dependence
of the expression at time t on previous
expression in the dynamic case we also
introduce a hidden markov model on the
states whereas in the sporadic case we
don't now because again we don't know
which condition we're in we introduce a
mark a mixture model over these two
possibilities and i haven't shown you
the possibility of equivalent expression
but that's also included in there
now we use a
parametric model that's very similar to
ebc but with this
hidden markov component built in
and you can see here the emissions
distribution is a beta negative binomial
just as we saw before and the mean in
that beta negative binomial is very
similar to what we saw before except it
has this c term here where cause c
equals c if s is up it equals one over c
if s is down and it equals one if
there's equivalent expression so you
could see the way in which this extends
edc
to accommodate
dependence in expression over these
ordered conditions
okay so simulations were done as before
we have negative binomial counts 10 000
genes
five time points in triplicate
so we simulated 15 percent to be dynamic
genes with some strong signal 15 with a
weak signal
15 sporadic genes for this strong signal
and 15 with the weak signal and 40 were
simulated to be constant
and then we evaluate ebc hmm and we
compare it to dec which is now dec2 and
edge r
and we can see
power
is is pretty good for all of these
methods
it's a little bit it's very comparable
when
the signal is strong
bbc hmm has a slight advantage when the
power is weak so by accommodating
dependence over the ordered conditions
we have a slight advantage in
identifying genes that are
changing but just changing a little bit
but they're changing consistently
so here are
uh examples of two genes identified
exclusively by edc hmm i'm showing you
simulated genes here in the upper panel
and then two genes
identified exclusively by edc hmm in our
case study data
just a second some things
so i'm getting a question here thank you
about what's the difference between
sporadic and dynamic so let me go back
just a sec
the difference between sporadic and
dynamic is that in dynamic we assume
that at every transition we see some
change
and sporadic we don't assume that so for
sporadic at a given
transition we could see equivalent
expression and then the next transition
we see up or down so here for example at
the first transition we see up
let me mark this just to say
this transition is up
this transition is up
this transition is up
this transition is down this transition
is down there's always some change
whereas in sporadic there's no change
here
and then there's up
and then there's down
followed by two transitions of no change
so sporadic is a mix between a constant
path where there's absolutely no change
at every transition and a dynamic path
where there is always change at every
transition
thanks for the question
so if you're interested in identifying
genes that have some change
over time
most of these methods work pretty well
like i said we have a slight advantage
in power
for genes that are changing what we call
weekly their signal just isn't as strong
but it's consistent
it's consistent across the ordered
conditions
but if you're looking to
assess where the changes are and what
the actual state space is so for every
transition what is the state is it down
up down up down down something like that
then ebc has some advantage because
again it's a bit like the analogy of
t-test to anova with an anova you can
identify
this gene is changing across conditions
but you can't quantify too easily you
have to do follow-up tests to quantify
um where that changes is the change
between the first two conditions the
first and the third whatever whereas the
mixture model approach quantifies those
uh for you that's the same for this uh
ebc hmm we quantify the state space
across conditions so you can say with
some confidence i want to see all genes
that have a 95 posterior probability of
being in the up up up down down down
pattern and evc hmm provides that so
that's the main advantage of that
approach
okay
now i want to spend a bit of time uh
talking about single cell rnac
and what we're doing in single cell rna
seq so here is um
a heat map where we have low expression
in green high expression in red zero
expression in white
for
genes
along the rows
and samples
along the columns
and we're looking at the the genes that
fall between the 60th and 70th
percentile of median normalized r sound
expression for these two data sets what
are some things that we notice between
single cell and bulk and i should say
that we've matched here the um
the library sizes so we're not looking
at really deep sequencing in the bulk
experiment and not deep sequencing the
single cell so these differences are not
due to
not um
entirely do or if they're
not due to sequencing them i'll say that
there's going to be some effective
sequencing depth but it's going to be
minimal here that's a good way to say so
what are the differences that you notice
well one is that you see a lot more
white in the single cell data right we
see a lot more zeros
you might notice there's increased
variability along
the uh for a given row or a given gene
along the samples and i don't think you
can see it here but i'll tell you that
there's increased multimodality
okay so features of single cell rna seq
data that we observe and then other
people have observed there's more zeros
for sure there's increased variability
and uh for a given
gene there's multi-modality increased
multimodality
way more than we see with um
bulk rna-seq and that's above and beyond
uh
being just due to the zeros so i'm not
talking about multi-modality that we
have a mode at zero and a mode of
non-zero but even without the zeros we
see increased multimodality so here's a
plot of just log variance for some bulk
um
rna-seq data sets shown in green and
then some
single cell
rna-seq data sets that are shown in pink
and with and without the zeros so you
can see sc1 sc2 se3 are single cell data
sets and then we've removed zeros and
you can see there's increased variance
in the single cell dataset just a second
getting a question
so the question is how do you define
bulk and what i mean by bulk rna-seq is
not single cell rna-seq so rna's
traditional rna-seq is what i mean by
bulk rna-seq thank you for the question
so in traditional i'll just back up here
so here we're looking at variance
for
single cell data sets and then
traditional
rna-seq data sets that are not single
cell data sets and we can see with the
single cell data as we might imagine
there's increased variability with the
bulk or the traditional rna-seq data
sets the signals that we're looking at
are an average across 10 000 or more
cells right and so we'd expect expect to
see decreased variability for that type
of data set
thank you
now here i i'm um
stressing the factor showing the fact
that we see increased multimodality with
uh the single cell data
so what we did here is we fit
uh m-plus which is a method for
identifying the number of modes in data
and we can see
for the
for the traditional rna-seq experiments
most of the genes have a single mode
this is within a given condition so
we're not looking at differential
expression here
um some of them have two modes and so on
the sample sizes are comparable so power
should be about profitable to say
whether or not there's two or more modes
in the single cell data we can see that
we often see two modes
um sometimes we see three modes and so
on so there's increased multimodality
with single cell data
okay so there's a number of um
questions that
we and others are working on with single
cell data a number of things that we're
excited about with single cell data
questions associated with normalization
with identifying differentially
regulated genes
the one i'm going to talk about today
is a question associated with
identifying oscillatory genes using
single cell rna-seq data so the the
challenge for us
in this project was to take snapshot
expression data meaning expression data
collected at a single point in time as
opposed to a time course experiment
where we would look at
data collected at multiple times we have
one given experiment i'll call that a
snapshot experiment and we want to see
can we identify genes that are
oscillating when we don't have time
forced data
so here i'm showing you four uh cells
again we're looking at single cell and i
have two genes in each cell and i'm
imagining them oscillating so gene one
and gene two in cell 1 in cell 2 and so
on and these are hypothetical profiles
hypothetical profiles of oscillation
what happens in the single cell rna-seq
experiment is that we collect data at
time t right there
so we don't see these oscillations that
i'm showing i'm just imagining
that they're there
now
if we could order if we could get some
idea
about how long
the genes had been oscillating then we
could reconstruct the oscillation right
so here i order the cells
by the amount of time that they've been
oscillating the genes in those cells
have been oscillating so
cell 4
has the slowest it's been oscillating it
has genes that are oscillating the
slowest amount of time
cell 1 is next
then comes cell three and then comes
cell two if i knew those numbers and i
ordered by oscillation time here
i could reconstruct the oscillation
one cycle of that oscillation is called
the base cycle okay now unfortunately i
don't know that
but it's it's interesting to think about
it'll come to play in just a minute
what i have i don't know that i have
data collected at time t here so how am
i going to figure out how long the genes
have been oscillating i can't if i order
by collection order i don't see anything
that's not showing up on my screen but
basically you don't see anything if you
order by collection order
what i can do
is i can figure out um
can i order the cells let me say in a
way that i can reconstruct one cycle of
the oscillation which we refer to as a
base cycle so here i'm showing you two
base cycles because i don't have any
time order i can't figure out does
cell 4 go here
or does it go in a different spot that's
identical
to it like near cell 2 right here i
can't figure out those differences right
but i can get some information on the
cell order
that allows me to reconstruct one cycle
of the oscillation which we call the
base cycle that order is called a cyclic
order
okay so how do we do that well first
this is an approach called osco and the
first thing we do is we screen for
candidate oscillators so independent of
order if you have genes that are
oscillating with similar frequencies and
you plot one against the other you will
see them showing up as some sort of
ellipse so we fit a model that looks for
patterns we call the paired sine model
but it basically it looks at
pairs of genes and it fits an elliptical
function to those pairs and it pulls out
ones where the residuals are small we
call those candidates so those are
oscillatory candidates
given the candidates we cluster them
into clusters and the clusters are based
on uh this paired sign model score so
the residuals again and ones that have
small residuals are oscillating with
similar frequencies they may be phase
shifted in fact they they almost are
almost always are phase shifted
and then from that we can recover the
order within each cluster okay within
each group of genes that has similar
frequency but its phase shifted we
recover the cyclic order which is again
the order of cells that allows us to
reconstruct one cycle of the oscillation
which we call base cycle and we do that
by extending
um
an algorithm called the nearest
insertion algorithm that was developed
for the traveling salesman problem so
with oscope we recognize a connection to
the traveling salesman problem
excuse me which is that given a list of
cities you only know the distances
between each pair of cities and i'm
showing you know pairs of cities below
and their distances and the goal is to
find an optimal route that visits each
city exactly once and returns to the
origin city
and optimal route is going to minimize
the overall distance travel
here
it's similar to the traveling salesman
problem but we have a gene cluster and
we want to find the optimal route
through all the cells
that returns to the first cell because
again we are we're trying to um
reconstruct an order i'm just going to
move that around where we start at cell
one and we move around and we come back
to cell one so in that way it's like
returning to the origin city
the optimal route is going to minimize
what
well that's sort of where the extension
comes in it minimizes expression
differences between observed and
baseline oscillations now the nearest
insertion algorithm was an algorithm
developed that um to address the
trembling salesman problem that works
pretty well we extended it to
accommodate our specific problem here so
we call that the extended nearest
insertion algorithm
just a sec i'm getting a question
okay so the question is what is a
bayesian approach and i think i'm going
to
get through that and then i'll answer
um that question
at the end
um okay so in terms of results i i want
to show you what what did we do what did
we do to validate results well we did
simulation studies of course i won't be
showing you the results of that today
but they're in our paper should you be
interested
um we also took
data where we know the answer from time
course experiments people have done a
bunch of time course experiments in a
bunch of different settings as
i assume everyone listening knows and
they've identified genes that are
oscillating and then in many cases they
validated those genes experimentally so
we took
a data set a microarray data set from
long ago
where it was a pretty large sample size
and they had validated the authors had
validated
a gold standard list of oscillating
genes
we ignore the time course order so we
just shuffle the data and we apply o
scope to see what we can recover
and um four of those genes are shown
here so on the right top panel
we show the known time course order and
and the actual profiles for each of
those four genes
and on the left we show the order
recovered by osco
you can see these genes are oscillating
with similar frequencies we can recover
that we can also recover the phase
shifts pretty well here
and here
where it's the highest point in that
base cycle that we see for each of these
genes
a second validation that we did is we
had identified a gene cluster that
seemed to be involved in cell cycle
because many of the genes were known to
be involved in cell cycle and so we
wanted to see if the order that
we recovered using oscope was consistent
with cell cycle and so the thompson lab
did an experiment where they labeled
cells and they could tell which part of
the cell cycle each cell was in and
we're showing here the eni extended
nearest insertion output and recovered
order on the left for four genes
in that cluster
and um
those same
genes
with labeled cells on the right hand
side so we have cells in the s phase
labeled blue and then g2 and g1 and you
can see that the order recovered by
oscope is in fact consistent with cell
cycle phases
there are a number of other validations
that i won't talk about today
so in summary and then i'll take the
time here at this
at this uh
break before i just close with a few
more slides to answer that question
about a bayesian approach so in summary
um
as i as i said in the first part of the
talk ebc was designed for inference uh
on identifying differentially expressed
isoforms it also works for identifying
differentially expressed genes
um osco
is a statistical pipeline for
characterizing oscillatory genes in a
snapshot single cell rna-seq experiment
and we're going to cross this one out
for a minute because that's what i'm
going to talk about in just a second i'm
sorry it's there um
let me just say briefly a bayesian
method
is one in which you introduce a prior
component so that you can evaluate
posterior probabilities
of
whatever you're interested in in our
case it's differential expression
and
we assume that the the targets of
interest the latent expression levels
are themselves random variables that's i
guess a quick way to think about it okay
in terms of availability uh ebc is in
bioconductor it's in galaxy and there's
a graphical user interface
the details are in bioinformatics in
2013 ebc hmm bioinformatics 2015.
what i'll
briefly close with is magic
that's also coming out in bioinformatics
in 2015 and oh scope is hopefully coming
out soon
so do i not have
okay so that's why that was let me just
say i thought i had a few other slides
on on magic um
magic is an approach that we developed
for identifying driver mutations in
cancer
um
and
it
so a number of methods are available for
identifying driving mutations in cancer
the earliest ones are what we call
frequency-based approaches where if a
gene is frequently mutated it has a
number of mutations a a very high number
of mutations across a patient's sample
it is called a driver
the trick with those methods is that you
have to figure out how big is big and so
you need to estimate a background
mutation rate and that background
mutation rate varies across the genome
so those methods are really focused on
identifying good models developing good
models and estimating uh accurate
background mutation rates so that they
can tell that this gene uh is
has a number of mutations that's far and
above what we would expect given this
background mutation rate that's
frequency-based approaches
then there are another class of
approaches that look at the functional
impact scores of various mutations and
if
a gene is enriched across a patient
population for mutations that have very
high functional impact those genes are
called drivers
so third class about position so where
in the gene have
mutations
compiled are they in important positions
in terms of amino acid
product in terms of the protein that's
produced
and so magic is an approach that unifies
those three considerations for
identifying driver genes in cancer and
it wasn't in my title but i wanted to
talk about it because we're excited
about it and we hope that
it can improve the current state of the
art in that area
so with that i will um
thank you for listening
um i'll thank my collaborators again in
the thompson lab ron stewart um
lee fong 2 should be on here victor
roddy helped with the earlier work my
former graduate student ning lang is the
first author on the ebc
work keegan courthouse first author on
magic and is helping with single cell
work now and working on problems in
single cell area as is rhonda walker um
and i am often hiring postdocs so with
that i'll
thank you for your time and i'm happy to
take more questions
thank you dr kendorsky for that
informative presentation before we get
started on a question and answer session
i'd like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the q a box
which can be found by clicking on the
green q a button at the lower left of
the presentation window
and
answered several questions
there appear to be no additional
questions from the audience
give them just a minute um
well as there appear to be no no further
questions from the audience we'll
conclude the presentation
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through november 13
2015 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye